[Musique]
ce qu'est ce que tu tiens entre les
mains et bien le petit livre rose c'est
à dire que c'était le guide le guide
rose et l espèce de gaultmillau des
bordels alors guide rose a nommé un
indicateur des maisons et salons de
société maisons de massage et de rendez
vous de paris province et colony 1934
alors là d'abord il ya évidemment des
publicités de toutes sortes
pour
les préservatifs la lingerie lingerie
lingerie spécialisés il ya même un peu
de publicité pour les pêcheurs ce qui
prouve que les tauliers sûrement se
livrer à ce genre de distraction pour le
champagne les vins et puis alors là on
trouve par exemple le un lit patron
soyez moderne adopté le costaud spéciale
pour maison de société et c'est aly fall
et bien évidemment des lits avec des
ressorts sérieux et tout pour les
étreintes là des maisons et puis alors
après après alors c'est la liste de
toutes les maisons d'abord de paris puis
de province plus des colonies avec le
nom des dames mais l'adresse salariés
même pas qui tarde à mimi madame
juliette madame georgette madame rachel
madame eliane madame alice enfin voilà
toutes ces dames qui avaient leurs
maisons et les maisons
le nom de la taulière qui ensuite la
maison s'appelait le fragonard
le sait
[Musique]
et
m
alors une apparente dans le 9ème y avait
beaucoup de maisons de tolérance on
appelait ça justement maison de société
alors celle-ci était spécialisé pour les
masochistes c'était paraît-il un endroit
très chère très luxueux et d'ailleurs
alors oui il ya une façade
extraordinaire simili gothique et tous
les gens qui passent devant se demande
ce que ça pouvait être puisque ça ça a
fermé il ya 40 ans dans une maison de ce
genre c'était des types qui venaient se
faire fouetter des types qui venaient se
faire torturer
qui se faisait fi sont simulés des
pendaisons décrue scission enfin c'était
vraiment le fin du fin et alors là on
avait les nanas en tenue de dompteuse
presque enfin avec les guêpières avec
les grandes bottes les fous et c'est en
général c'était une clientèle riche
parce que c'était des endroits qui
coûtait très cher alors on m'a dit enfin
j'ai lu des textes et puis on m'a dit
qu'il y avait de temps en temps quand
même le type qui n'était pas riche mais
qui faisait ses économies vous n'êtes
pas sur son petit salaire pour venir se
faire fouetter c'est
nous habite le quartier depuis pas mal
d'années et puis on connaissait facettes
une maison qui était assez folklorique
c'était une maison de maisons de passe
un beau pinard qu'on appelle
d'ailleurs voyez encore quelques statues
qui peuvent rester en prison il reste
plus que la niche maintenant mais dans
le temps il y avait des statuts qui
était assez érotique qui était assez
drôle puis il se passait des choses
assez intéressantes à l'intérieur ce
qu'on en parlait dans le quartier oui
c'était connu c'était connu mon dieu
c'était connu surtout paris et c'était
le 9 florent le 9 navarrenx était
s'étaient connus et reconnus
e
oh
hop
eh bien on a on a changé de quartier né
dans le quartier saint sulpice ont eu
tout à côté de l'église saint-sulpice et
là il ya une petite maison en 36 qui
était tenu autrefois par une certaine
madame baby et alors là sous toutes
réserves ont dit que la clientèle du
fait de la proximité de l'église
saint-sulpice était une clientèle
d'ecclésiastiques alors venez là des
prêtres en civil n'est ce pas que les
[ __ ] reconnaissent et plus ou moins
puisqu'ils avaient en général la tonsure
et puis des grosses godasses noire
qu'ils avaient un genre particulier a ri
pak les filles qui étaient recrutés là
étaient des filles un peu spécialisés
pour ce genre de messieurs qui était
bien éduqués qui avait souvent été dans
une des écoles religieuses quand elle
j'étais jeune et alors
comme on est juste en face de l'église
alors on pense que ces curés allait la
faire leurs petites affaires comme
c'était un péché c'est le péché de la
chair vite y rentrer dans l'église elle
avait juste le temps de traverser la rue
et retrouver un autre curé qu'il est
qu'on fait c'est donner l'absolution et
l'autre à son tour parti pour
voir une fille et puis voilà ça se
passait comme ça
seulement le
ouais
[Musique]